brittany's on the line
in new hampshire hi brittany how are you
hi good how are you
great how can we help um you're probably
gonna yell at her
i'm probably gonna what yell at me maybe
no i'm not oh
no you probably will dave
so we have a six month old baby
um and my fiance and i um we're supposed
to get married twice
by now but because of the pandemic it's
gotten pushed back um
so we have 88
000 in debt um and we have the option to
move in with my mom
with the baby of course um and my aunt
also was there so it's kind of like a
my aunt moved in there because she had
financial problems so i don't know if
you would recommend like we sell our
house and move in there or if we just
right through the debt hold on dave
dave's not going to yell at you
okay i i i'm not going to yell at you
but i'm going to tell you no
okay i'm going to tell you no and here's
why
i don't even want to answer your first
question dave may come back and answer
that but
ex help walk me through this process why
is the pandemic pushing off the wedding
like how come we just can't go down to
the courthouse you're already living
together
you know you're already i hear a lot of
we so just go to the courthouse
get married and then if y'all want to
have a bigger wedding do that whenever
y'all feel comfortable doing that but
help me convince me to why you cannot
get married
today well yeah we've talked about that
um but i guess we just wanted our
families there
so well your family can be there invite
them to the courthouse with you
they have to travel um they live like
across the country yeah they can come to
the celebration
yeah because you're already doing
everything that married people do you
might as well be married
as well it's just a formality first
stage of the game now who owns the house
that you like um we we go on it
okay please get married this week yeah
do you understand what happens if he
dies because he doesn't have a will
uh-huh you do you understand what
happens if he dies
um not really you and your baby are now
partners
with his heirs in the house that you
live in
this is how dumb this is yeah yeah
he doesn't have a will and you are in a
partnership
and so i assume like his mom and dad are
probably his heirs
right his child is one of his heirs
and the state will give the other half
of the house that you live in
to his mom and dad and his kid which
happens to be your kid
messy messy messy messy thing that
happens
and then you're gonna call me up and be
a broken-hearted young lady that
please please get these things in order
and go do this immediately no you don't
need to move in with your parents no
what is um what is his income um
70. what is your income i just got hours
cut so i'm only making about five
five thousand dollars a year five
thousand dollars a year
yeah like 200 or 400 a month
right now all right so you got to get a
different job this one sucks
yep you don't have a job it's a joke
yeah
pretty much how much is the mortgage
payment brittany
14.50 yeah okay so
here's the thing i'm going to give you
ramsey plus for a year
as a wedding gift right yeah
okay no because i'm afraid for you
young lady yeah you're in a very
precarious
situation legally and relationally right
now
and um you you don't even know what you
don't know
about how badly this can go for you so
you guys need to get married and then do
a celebration later on when the family
can come to town
that being delayed for pandemic i
understand but i'm with anthony
get in touch with a local pastor and um
let's
step out on the front porch and have
whoever lives in town come by
and uh you know we'll have a little
miniature celebration
tonight you're going to you got to get
blood tests get paperwork but i mean
probably the end of the week
but you you're really in a dangerous
situation
there's no will and you're in a general
partnership
and there's a baby you guys are going to
be more responsible than this
and so i'm not yelling at you i didn't
raise my voice i'm just worried about
you